do you know that feeling when you're
doing exactly what you were put on the
earth to do the one where it's like
everything inside you is moving together
in harmony with the universe
me neither
but you know one can hope right
wave the mommy because she'll hate me
even more than she already does if you
don't I seen her call you saying that
becoming a lawyer would only crush your
soul yeah it is I'm running a business
and right now that business is getting a
journalist in and out of paledonia
[Applause]
no no and no
who's a journalist I have resigned my
position here
20 grams as you are
welcome president finaga so nice to meet
you
you must take a selfie um you approve
there are so many wonderful things about
my country
all right
oh
stay here
what the hell just happened you're one
man's security detail happened he's a
hero I'm with the president of a country
in the middle of a coup this is the
scoop of a lifetime you got to be alive
down the scoop for a lifetime
you never should have come let's go
can't just leave him
[Music]
I'm just doing my job
thank you
did you help
get up again now I got to win I get up
again
not the time for coaching man
my God
oh Color Me impressed Mr petite
at all
run
[Music]